hi I'm Erik Bosse and of interest in
games loosest of loose threads was this
slippery fella Loki who back in 2012 had
the sense to grab the tesseract and
portal the hell away avoiding a future
visit with the world's worst
chiropractor and recently Marvel head
Kevin Feige revealed some major details
about where Loki went and how Loki's
upcoming Disney Plus series starring Tom
Hiddleston will unleash the god of
mischief in his own mischievous corner
of the MCU
I'm gonna break down these details from
Feige and explain some missable
implications from that endgame scene and
spoiler warning in case any my
speculation ends up being right and
ruined your life so recently there was
this tweet showing a leaked image of
Kevin Feige speaking at a Disney
investor conference about the Loki
series with some concept art featuring
some interesting Easter eggs so let's
break down this tweet with another new
rockstars
tweet down okay this concept art depicts
Loki in the year 1975 behind him there's
an ad for the movie Jaws which came out
in the summer of 75 and Loki's wearing
seventies clothes rocking a turtleneck
is walking past others and Stephanie's
attire and seventies era cars kind of
like that scene with Hoffman and void
and Midnight Cowboy this is a Midnight
Cowboy reference this could be a Rick
and Morty parallel because this Loki
series showrunner is a longtime Rick and
Morty writer Michael Waldron and that
animated show has made a lot of nods to
that film this Loki Disney Plus series
has been described as the god of
mischief popping up throughout human
history as an unlikely influencer on
historical events now that doesn't mean
Loki will be time-traveling it could
just mean that history will be retconned
with Loki having already influenced
events since he's an Asgardian demigod
and he's lived for hundreds and hundreds
of years and 1975 was an interesting
year in human history it was the year
American forces withdrew from Saigon the
end of the war in Vietnam perhaps Loki
could play a role in the Saigon
evacuation September 75 was also the
year President Gerald Ford survived two
assassination attempts the first from a
member of the Charles Manson cult may be
Loki will use the space stone to curb
the bullets July 1975 was the first ever
joint u.s. Soviet space flight between
the NASA Apollo shuttle in the Soviet
Soyuz 19 capsule a symbol of the cooling
of tensions between the superpowers in
the 70s maybe
he could prevent nuclear war by making
the space race a friendlier one or maybe
rescuing these astronauts and cosmonauts
in space to avoid an accident in which
these superpowers would blame each other
now jaws came out in June 75 and it was
still in theaters in July and is really
the first Hollywood blockbuster it
stayed in theaters for months in months
expanding internationally as late as
December 75 so really a lot of these
historical events could have occurred
around jaws release but for other ideas
of Loki's next steps let's re-examine
that scene in Avengers endgame during a
time heist present-day Starks Scott Lang
a cap sneaked into o start our soon to
be Avengers tower they steal the
tesseract which contains a space stone
and Loki's scepter which contains the
mind stone while the 2012 Avengers are
escorting away a defeated Loki cap gets
the sceptre checks out his own ass then
Stark and Scott debilitate 2012 start to
briefly get the briefcase containing the
tesseract but 2012 Hulk pissed from
having to take the stairs slams the door
in present-day Stork space causing the
tesseract to slide over to Loki's feet
he grabs it portals out so where does
Loki go well as explained elsewhere in
the film this kind of meddling with the
past creates a new alternate branch
timeline I started to explain this a bit
and my full breakdown of all the new MC
universes opened up by endgame go check
that out
but Loki taking the tesseract has
created a new timeline of his own with
him still alive living his life as he
would have from 2012 onward now in 2012
Loki's mission on earth was to retrieve
the space stone for Thanos but Loki
probably would not go right back to the
mad Titan this second because think
about it
this Loki lost the mine stone in the
scepter which was probably given to him
by phantoms basically he traded one of
the Ennis's stones for another when he's
supposed to come back with - and yeah
the mad Titan doesn't respond well to
this kind of trickery so bookies first
move would probably be to try to use the
space stone to retrieve the scepter now
we have to assume that cap returned the
mine stone back to the exact point in
time from which it was taken meaning the
scepter would be back in the hands of
Hydra Sitwell rumlow pierce dr. lists
etc but date blue god Rock that allows
you to teleport anywhere spatially move
objects would be pretty useful to break
into wherever Hydra moved the mind stone
next and to steal it now assuming cap
restored the timeline Loki would fail
right because we're story in a timeline
means the mind stone stays with dr. list
until the Avengers get it back
use it to make vision and age Voltron in
2015 but remember Loki's escape created
a new branch timeline where history
plays out totally differently so in that
branch Loki could still have gotten a
mine stone and Thanos his stone quests
could have started a lot sooner but
knowing Loki it's possible that stealing
the tesseract means he's not too
interested in honoring this contract
with daños is really the balance of
power would have shifted here Loki has a
space stone and Thanos is left with no
army and no infinity stone which puts
Loki in a unique position really the
universe would be his oyster assuming he
would want to leave Earth and avoid the
Avengers he could return to Asgard or
travel to MCU destinations like Zander
country axia a la nowhere Sicard
using that space stone to split away
from the mad Titan who's hunting him
down similar to Rick Sanchez the selfish
genius antihero of Rick and Morty
constantly on the run from various
interdimensional authorities and
sometimes even doing the right thing
with Waldron as the voice of this series
Tom Hiddleston involved Kevin Feige and
the production value that Disney Plus
will likely bring to it
Loki might be the most exciting release
in Marvel's future comment down below
with where you think Loki went and
follow me on Instagram and Twitter at
Evo subscribe to new rock stars or more
at Marvel spots and theories thank you
for joining me and if fluky series pilot
is just low-key breaking the shark robot
on the set of jaws forcing Spielberg to
hide the thread and accidentally make a
better movie have a huge career and give
all of us better movies to watch that
would honestly be pretty awesome
[Music]